[Music]
is there any scenario which the
president would select his vice
president kamala harris for the supreme
court
again i'm not going to speak to any
considerations preparations lists when
you were asked about the vice president
possibly being selected as a supreme
court nominee you said you're not going
to speak to any considerations does that
mean she is being considered
well justice breyer's retirement ramping
up speculation about who president biden
will pick to fill his seat when spryer
officially announces the resignation and
whether it just might be the vice
president of the united states could be
well here with what we can expect fox
news at night host shannon bream shannon
tell us how this all unfolded earlier i
said that we had broken the story it
turns out that you broke the news that
he was surprised you had heard he was
surprised by how all this unfolded tell
us more about that
yeah you know we started to hear the
rumblings yesterday that this
announcement was coming and by the way
we still don't have an official
announcement from justice breyer or from
the supreme court um so of course we
immediately start calling around uh and
several people that i talked to
yesterday ultimately told me that
yesterday was not the day for this
announcement justice breyer was not
planning it uh and i his emotions were
described to me a lot of different ways
there was some consternation
but there was you know more surprise i'm
told from a lot of people that listen he
made this decision firmly some time ago
there was no change or pressure he said
on him but he decided this was the right
time for him at the age of 83 after
decades on the bench to step down but he
was not ready for the announcement
yesterday although we were told it is
imminent uh and he was i'm told by one
person blindsided by what happened
yesterday but it does take it changed
the dialogue in the country we're not
talking about the failure the voting
rights act the standoff in russia we're
not talking about buildback better uh
coming back with a new version we're
talking about this so politically you
could see shannon being that you're in
washington all things politics you could
see politically how the administration
would like to change the conversation
yeah i can see how that would be a good
time for the white house but again what
i'm told is that this this announcement
was very close anyway and that it was a
decision justice breyer had made so it
certainly is beneficial to the white
house and gets us on a whole new
conversation about what happens next
with the court what the white house may
do certainly changes the conversation
that's right uh and politico with their
playbook this morning they say on the
latter point the timing could not be
more opportune the defeat of the voting
rights bill last week was a final straw
for many voters of color disenchanted
with the lack of action on that issue as
well as on police reform recent q poll
showed the president's approval with
black voters down to 57 from 78 a year
ago perhaps that's why the white house
wasted no time in
leaking the information it's presumed
somebody there leaked it but how exactly
now shannon does this work
you know he's still gonna have the job
for almost six months it seems
you know it seems odd that you would
figure out who's going to take his place
until he's closer to the end of his tour
well i mean to me i just thought
politically it would make more sense for
the white house if this was a later
announcement only because then you're
leading into the midterms you have the
summer for people focused on this you
can get out there and campaign as
democrats saying the senate's so
important these kinds of battles are the
reason we need to hold on to the senate
so just from a political sense it seemed
a little bit early to me but they can
start this whole process we've talked
about the names some of these candidates
have been vetted that will intensify now
you could go ahead and have a nomination
and to have people start
working through the confirmation process
meeting the senators being investigated
by the judiciary committee over in the
senate so a lot of that process can kick
off and and be well done potentially by
the end of june or july when we would
expect that justice pryor would say this
is the end of the term and i'm out yeah
but they realize timing is everything
and if they lose the midterms then the
republicans would have a say in who's
nominated this would motivate the banks
right that's right
but what about kamala harris i mean your
son peter ducey asked about kamala
harris could she be a supreme court
justice and i was reading i mean it's
obvious i didn't have to but someone
brought this up in an article 50 50
right now for voting and if she
if it came down to 50 50 she could make
the time
she they would go to her for the
tiebreaker
well it's interesting because uh a few
years back when it was the trump pence
administration there was an argument by
a number of legal scholars that if the
senate tied on a supreme court
confirmation they argued that vice
president pence could not be the
tie-breaking vote that it technically
has to be 51 senators so we'll see if
they would feel that way this time
around uh i think that plucking the vice
president from where she is and putting
her into this position would create a
whole other domino effect of headaches
for the white house if they had to get a
vice president confirmed and all kinds
of other things so i think she's a long
shot
but her name is certainly out there in
the mix you know a lot of people think
about justice briar democrats and
republicans i think about you when
announcements like this happens your day
gets expanded by 18 hours true so i
think we we're not dream centric enough
well i will tell you i was actually out
running with my dog yesterday and my
phone blew up and i was about two miles
from home and i'm dragging the dog stop
stuffing let's go and i'm trying to call
people and running at the same time so
our days are interesting i love the job
and the supreme court keeps us busy all
right your dog got a shorter walk we'll
explain to him later
good job shannon thank you